Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Muriel de Meo
Anche in mezzo a bombe, minacce e bugie,
il mio desiderio è sempre quello:
tenere aperte delle finestre umoristiche.
Da quando è riapparsa la guerra
in Europa, nei balcani,
e dopo l'11 settembre,
ho disegnato molte vignette sulla guerra,
e sulle sue conseguenze:
questo disordine globale
in cui siamo immersi.
E poi, quando le raccolgo
per libri, o per mostre,
le intreccio sempre alle vignette
sulla violenza maschile contro le donne:
le due cose sono, appunto,
strettamente intrecciate.
Io collaboro dagli anni '80
con i primi centri antiviolenza,
come il CADMI.
E ho scelto questo registro -
l'umorismo, l'ironia -
anche per questo argomento.
Al centro della guerra,
dei fumetti sulla guerra,
è nata una personaggia:
il suo nome è "Cassandra che ride".
La sua antenata è la Cassandra omerica,
veggente, sacerdotessa,
nata a Troia 3.000 anni fa.
Le sue profezie, perlopiù di sciagura,
erano destinate a non essere
credute, ascoltate.
E per questo, Cassandra
si sentiva impazzire.
Una scrittrice tedesca, Christa Wolf,
ha avuto un'intuizione su di lei.
Ha detto:
"Un tratto umoristico in ogni pazzia.
Chi sa riconoscerlo, e usarlo, ha vinto."
La mia "Cassandra che ride", infatti,
ha trovato nell'umorismo,
in questo linguaggio,
la possibilità di una via d'uscita.
La possibilità di riproporzionare le cose,
e di dare, o riportare, a una misura umana
fatti che sembrano enormi.
E incontrollabili.
E quindi, la possibilità
di tenere la testa a posto.
Per fare questo,
l'umorismo ha tante chiavi:
ne racconto due.
Una è che chi fa umorismo parte
sempre da una posizione di debolezza.
È apparente, forse: però di debolezza,
come quella dei bambini
che dicono la verità
o quella di Cassandra,
che non era creduta.
Però nel gioco, complesso
e anche istintivo, dell'umorismo
questa debolezza
si trasforma in una forza.
Che spiazza in un lampo,
e poi molto sinteticamente.
È una forza che poi crea un piacere.
E poi, l'umorismo è un atto relazionale:
ha bisogno di compagnia,
di condividere questo piacere
con altre, altri.
È un invito al gioco.
E questo è per me, credo,
il sogno, il desiderio
che davvero è diventato realtà
nel poter fare un lavoro
che è un invito a giocare insieme.
L'altra cifra è che bisogna stare
in compresenza e in prossimità
con l'oggetto di cui si tratta,
per fare un lavoro davvero efficace.
E questo vale principalmente
per la satira:
non potrei fare battute, scherzi,
su stereotipi culturali di civiltà
che non conosco bene,
di cui non ho una una percezione forte,
che non mi toccano veramente alle radici.
Lo posso fare su cose
che in qualche modo
risuonano dentro di me.
E da cui sono molto toccata,
che sento sulla pelle.
E succedeva così
anche ai buffoni di corte,
che dovevano stare lì,
presso il trono del re,
per vedere da lì,
e illuminare, in un attimo,
gli intrighi della cortigianeria,
gli eccessi del potere regale;
e succede così anche alle donne
che irridono l'orco di turno,
come è nella cronaca
di questi ultimi tempi.
Ma nella sua essenza,
io credo che l'intento
di chi fa questo, di chi fa umorismo,
sia molto simile a quello del bambino
nella fiaba di Andersen,
cioè svelare che il re è nudo!
[Cassandra che ride]
[- È in atto uno scontro di civiltà
- Vedo lo scontro, ma non la civiltà]
[- Vengono a liberarci dal Burqa
- Il corpo lo possiamo tenere?]
[Prima le donne e i bambini!]
[- La violenza si ferma
solo con altra violenza]
[Allora quando si ferma?]
[- Combatteremo fino all’ultimo uomo]
- Finalmente sole!]
[Sto riscoprendo il maschio
selvaggio che è in me]
[Da che stilista vai?]
[Lui mi maltratta.
Tu cosa faresti al mio posto?]
[Cambierei posto!]
[- M’ama, non m’ama
- M’ammazza, non m’ammazza]
[Ultima specie a rischio]
[Un altro caso di violenza sulle donne!]
[Dopo averla immobilizzata sul divano,
i due animali sopra di lei
ne ebbero finalmente ragione]
(Applausi)
Vengo da una famiglia con molte donne,
che sono state le protagoniste,
il pubblico originario dei miei fumetti.
Il teatro familiare era denso
di tensioni, drammi, melodrammi;
e questo linguaggio è stato, per me,
la possibilità di dire
la mia verità, di dire la mia;
e di farlo facendo, anche,
ridere le mie sorelle.
Poi, a 20 anni, erano gli anni '70,
ho incontrato il femminismo,
che ha nutrito, e fortemente incoraggiato,
il mio desiderio di usare
pubblicamente questo linguaggio,
di, letteralmente, "pubblicare".
E di farlo non partendo
da astratte rivendicazioni
di diritti o da ideologie,
ma di farlo partendo proprio da me,
dalle mie emozioni, esperienze
e dalla consapevolezza
che si andava generando
nello scambio con le altre.
Oggi, quando mi metto alla scrivania -
io disegno sulla carta, prima di tutto -
sono preda delle emozioni più discordanti:
possono essere molto confusa
su quello che andrò a trattare,
posso essere molto arrabbiata.
Ci sono tanti motivi:
posso essere molto ansiosa -
perché sono molto, molto, molto ansiosa -
e però a poco a poco,
nel farsi del lavoro,
nel farsi dell'opera,
a poco a poco, cercando un equilibrio
fra il testo e l'immagine,
che è l'arte del fumetto,
affinando uno sguardo
o la metrica della battuta,
addentrandomi a poco a poco,
alla fine trovo una via d'uscita.
E la realtà stessa
si trasforma davanti ai miei occhi.
Questo può avvenire su tutto:
sul mondo, sui rapporti fra i sessi,
sulla guerra, sulla cucina,
sulle opere liriche,
sulla violenza, come avete visto,
sul femminismo - su tutto.
Dedico molto spazio, da molti anni,
al tema del lavoro.
Ho disegnato decine e decine,
diventate centinaia,
di annunci ironici di lavoro.
È una ossessione.
E poi anche lì sono nate delle personagge.
Di solito io non caratterizzo tanto
i personaggi, sono quasi archetipi.
E però, a volte, ad alcuni
dò dei nomignoli
e diventano un po'
come delle padrone di casa,
qualcuno che dà il la
a conversazioni, a dialoghi.
E nel lavoro è nata
"La bella addormentata
fa il turno di notte"
che racconta i cambiamenti, le crisi,
i punti di crisi provocati
dalle donne e nelle donne,
dall'ingresso nel mercato del lavoro -
non dico mondo,
perché si è sempre lavorato.
E l'ultima nata
è la "Bracciante Digitale",
che lotta contro lo strapotere
dei latifondisti del web.
Naturalmente anch'io,
come la bracciante digitale,
come la bella addormentata,
anch'io nel mio lavoro
sono coinvolta nella crisi,
nei grandi stravolgimenti del lavoro
nei campi che sono miei propri:
il giornalismo, l'editoria e l'arte.
E però ci sto dentro, con il mio lavoro:
ci sto dentro elaborandolo,
testimoniando con le vignette,
e in qualche modo
trasformandolo in questo modo.
È in questo senso, per me,
un'azione politica,
una lotta di liberazione
con armi leggere, molto molto leggere.
Che cosa accadrebbe,
se non ci fosse più niente da ridere?
Non lo so,
perché "Cassandra che ride"
non prevede la fine del mondo.
[Pat Carra | Aida]
[Stephane Grappelli | L’internazionale]
[Ti dono le stesse opportunità
e capacità degli uomini]
[Dopo mezzanotte,
posso tornare me stessa?]
[Biancaneve]
[Dite al principe azzurro
che prima di svegliarmi
faccia i sette lettini,
stiri le sette camicie
e lavi i quattordici calzini]
[La mano dice che diventerai
ricca e famosa]
[Solo che non ho tolto i guanti]
[La nostra azienda è una grande famiglia]
[A che ora si mangia?]
[Finalmente sono riuscita
a conciliare famiglia e lavoro.]
[Sono single e disoccupata.]
[Le donne devono avere
potere come gli uomini]
[Di che sesso deve essere chi lo subisce?]
[Rivoluzione Tecnologica]
[Forse conviene
cercare lavoro come robot.]
[Plurilaureata cerca lavoro
adeguato alle sue pluri illusioni]
[Ciao mamma, esco a cercare lavoro.]
[Non dimenticarti il passaporto!]
[Ti ricordi come eravamo ricche,
quando ci davano la paghetta?]
[Mi sono fatta suora molto tardi.]
[Spero di fare in tempo a diventare Papa.]
(Applausi)